mr. Weinstein Hannah Thomas Peter from
Sky News
I wondered sir could you tell me do you
believe all of those women are lying
do you believe they're lying sir
thank you very much are you ashamed any
messages for the women
Harvey Weinstein leaves his lawyer's
office in New York one year on since he
was accused of sexual harassment and
assault Rose McGowan was one of the
first to come forward with her Weinstein
story helping to spark the me2 movement
and with it a global reckoning on
consent and the abuse of power I can't
say that I anticipated the global aspect
of it but I was hoping that it would
show people everywhere that they could
topple a power structure that it would
have a big domino effect silence for 20
years I have been slut-shamed
I've been harassed would you call what
has been sparked a revolution I think
it's completely revolutionary I can't
remember the last time there was one
other than you know there's a civil
rights movement there's the gay rights
movement we needed a revolution we
needed a reset women have played nice
for a real long time I didn't suspect it
was getting women very far but for Rose
McGowan the revolution is far from over
do you think there are other Harvey
Weinstein's out there in Hollywood I
know for a fact there are other Harvey
Weinstein's in Hollywood right now I can
name 20 people off the top of my head
right now that's shocking
not really it's Hollywood they think if
they get the ugly guy gone and they can
return to their like perfect-looking
world and still continue as they
continue many of the women who broke
their silence against Weinstein shared
the sense that one man in handcuffs
simply isn't enough
no woman at any stage of her life should
be told that you have to do a sexual act
in order to have a career I'm sorry but
it's pretty basic it's really
mind-blowing that women are treated this
way and and that we have all been told
we have to just put up with it it's just
the way it is well guess what
that way anymore it's important for
other men to know you want to back this
way then you're gonna lose everything
with a class-action lawsuit under way
that could well happen to Harvey
Weinstein
but those accused of protecting him may
also pay a high price and for some that
is the most important shift the
environment has to be changed you know
the system that enables the behavior you
know this is much bigger than Harvey
Weinstein and it's much bigger than
gender it's about power and it's about
how we respond as a culture to power
Harvey Weinstein denies all allegations
of non-consensual behavior but if his
criminal trial proceeds it will be yet
another moment in which the power and
the limitations of me2 are tested a
referendum on an era in which everything
seemed to change Hana Thomas Peter Sky
News in New York